So, this week....
this week, America chose
our next president-- a hat.
(laughter)
If that's not disturbing enough,
we just realized that
while we were immersed
in the year-long Army crawl
through diarrhea
that was the 2016 campaign,
that really kind of feels like,
"All that (bleep)
Andy Dufresne crawled through
-to get out of prison."
-(laughter)
There was a bunch
of piping-hot fire emoji
content from the World Wide Web
that we didn't get to cover,
like Vladimir Putin
awarding Steven Seagal
-Russian citizenship, huh?
-(audience groaning)
And you didn't even know.
Now you do.
This daring heist to steal 50
grand worth of bull semen, huh?
(laughter and groaning)
Very exciting.
I hope it was already
out of the bull
-when they tried to steal it.
-(laughter)
And this nightmare-inducing
Lego man cosplay.
(laughter and groaning)
This looks like
a Batman villain happened.
It was just like he fell
into a vat at the Lego factory,
and then became this guy.
So, tonight, we're gonna revisit
some of the comedy gold
we failed to mine
during the election
because we're pretty
(bleep) tired
about talking
about this (bleep) election.
Like, we totally
missed this one.
-(person clapping) -Elon Musk...
Thank you, one guy.
-We totally missed...
-(laughter, applause)
Elon Musk...
I know, you guys want
to still keep talking about it.
Elon Musk, the handsome
billionaire inventor
who's one-accident-in-a-lab fire
away
from being
his own origin story...
Maybe he's that guy.
I don't know.
Maybe... maybe this is Elon
Musk, 2025. We don't know.
But he said
that we are definitely living
in a Matrix-style simulation.
The Telegraph quoted him
as saying, "Maybe we should be
"hopeful this is a simulation
because otherwise,
"we're gonna create simulations
indistinguishable from reality,
or civilization ceases
to exist."
So, let me ask you this.
If this is a simulated reality,
why in the world would someone
virtually create
-this, a blobfish? Why?
-KIRKMAN: Ah.
-(laughter and groaning)
-HARDWICK: Why?
And why does it look so sad?
-It's like a...
-(laughter)
It's like a grumpy catfish,
or...
or he looks like the Ziggy
comics, but, like, really old.
-(laughter)
-I think Elon Musk
could be onto something
with the Matrix theory.
So, comedians, what other movie
could we use to explain reality?
Jen Kirkman.
Um, Back to the Future,
because the Cubs won,
a fascist is running things,
and hoverboards look stupid.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(applause and cheering)
Points. Points.
It's technically
Back to the Future II,
-but that's all right.
-(laughter)
-KIRKMAN: Sorry.
-Sean.
Uh, Gigli, because it sucks,
and I make no money.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
Matt Braunger.
In two years, The Hunger Games.
Right now, Titanic.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(audience groaning, applause)
"Gentlemen, it's been a pleasure
working with you."
-(Hardwick humming like violin)
-Let's hope...
(laughter)
(imitates water gurgling)
-(laughter)
-(imitates water gurgling)